This is the simplified fraction, fantastic work if you found it. I think it's
best to start by reducing the factors of x plus one and x plus five. These
factors in the numerator and denominator cancel or reduce to one. I don't want
to forget about these monomial terms, but everything looks a little confusing
right now. So I'm going to rewrite my line. So we have two x-squared, times x
plus three, times two x minus five, for our numerator. For the denominator we
have x minus 3 times 6x times 2x plus 1. Notice that I switched the order of
this 6x and this x minus 3. We can do that since we're multiplying here. We know
the multiplication is commutative. We know 2/6 reduces to 1/3 so I can simplify
this fraction. We can also simplify our powers of x we have x squared in the
numerator and 1 x in the denominator so we'll be left with 1 x in our numerator
in our final answer. I'll show it more easily by writing x squared as x times x.
We simplify each of these x's since they really equal 1, and 2 divided by 2
equals 1, and 2 into 6 equals 3. This gives us our final answer.